لقد كان العثور على طريقة للجلوس بشكل صحيح
أمرًا هائلاً ، كنت أعاني من نوع من
آلام أسفل الظهر واستمر في ذلك لسنوات في
تلك المرحلة ، فإن كيفية جلوسك أمر مهم
لأن هذه عادةً هي اللحظة
التي تقرر فيها كيفية وضع حوضك
وهو الأساس  إلى عمودك الفقري
ولكن كل الانحناء في تجويف الورك
بحيث يكون الذيل خارجًا وحرًا ثم
يسمح للركبتين بالانحناء دون
تغيير موضع الذيل ووضع
حوضك لأسفل في
تجويف الورك ثم الاسترخاء بشكل أساسي
صدرك لأسفل ، هذا وضع جلوس جيد
لأنك تحمل
وزن جسمك في عظامك وليس
في عضلاتك عندما تكون هياكل
ظهرك وعظامك الخلفية التي من
المفترض أن تحافظ على جسمك
عندما تكون في  المكان المناسب والمحاذاة بشكل صحيح
والقيام بعملهم
ويمكن لبقية جسمك الاسترخاء ، والآن
ابدأ بثني ركبتيك الآن أعتقد أنه
بمجرد أن أتمكن من الجلوس جيدًا ، يمكنني
الحفاظ على هذا الموقف بشكل أساسي لذلك يمكنني
كن مرتاحًا بهذه الطريقة
طوال الوقت الذي تعرفه وهو
أمر رائع حقًا